Okay, let's listen.
Hold on.
And we're going to go to the debate
itself, but here is this Cor
Oh my goodness.
Eusebius book four.
>> You said because book four is actually
where he quotes
>> I would encourage you to read Eusebius
book four.
>> You said because book four is actually
where he quotes it the way that I said
it, but
>> He quotes it both ways. Okay, perfect.
So would you say that there is a sort of
variant reading in Matthew 28:19 then
because if he's quoting it both ways,
then you would have to say that both
readings exist, right? No, I
Now, she thinks that she's being slick
and smart in trying to catch Lady Logic
in this argument and I'll break it down.
We'll break this down step by step, but
I'm going to go to the other link then
we're going to go to debate and see if
we can find the full clip.
>> wouldn't have to say that there's a
variant reading in the text. I would say
that when the church fathers are
reciting it or writing about it, they
can either paraphrase it or they can
quote it directly. So in this case, he
quotes it directly and he paraphrases
it. I would encourage Very impressed
with her response.
Very impressed.
It is a blessing from the triune God,
the Lord Jesus Christ.
When God will bring a godly man into
life of a godly woman
or bring a godly woman into life of a
godly man, you are blessed. That's
Proverbs 18:22.
Very impressed with her response.
Right? And I'm going to break down what
the argument is, but let me find the
fuller clip.
Let me find the fuller clip cuz you may
not be aware of this debate argument.
A typical tactic of Unitarians or
anti-Trinitarians
is to point to Eusebius of Caesarea.
Eusebius of Caesarea
who when he references
our Lord Jesus' command
to go and baptize believers, he says
baptize them in the name of the Lord.
You guys, class has begun, right? You
want to hear, right? All right, I want
you to hear. We're going into the meat.
Let's go into the meat. All right, I
need you to listen.
What up, brother?
Okay, into the meat.
So
one way they get around Matthew 28:19,
guys, Matthew 28:19. We're going to go
into the fathers as well.
They all tell you that
Eusebius,
the church historian,
when he
makes mention
of the instruction of our Lord Jesus
Christ
to go and baptize
he quotes it as go and baptize in the
name of the Lord.
Then they use that to argue, you see
Matthew 28:19 where it says
and go baptize them into the name of the
Father and of the Son and Holy Spirit is
a later interpolation.
That's not the original text of Matthew.
That was added by Trinitarians. So Cora,
I guess has not read my responses.
She hasn't been trained adequately.
That argument has been destroyed ages
ago.
So what is God Logic's wife saying? Lady
Logic, here it is. The fuller clip then
we're going to go into the video to see
if there's more to the context.
In Matthew 28:19, Jesus says go out and
baptize in the name of the Father, the
Son, and the Spirit. As a Muslim, can
you go out and do a religious right in
the name of Allah, Muhammad, and
Jibreel? Allah? Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Jibreel?
>> Right. So when Jesus is saying go out
and perform this religious right,
baptism, because that's how we enter the
faith, that in the name of the singular
name of the Father, the Son, and the
Spirit. What is he teaching here?
>> Are you familiar with how this verse is
quoted within church father writings?
Yes.
Isn't it ironic?
She goes, "Are you familiar how this is
quoted in the church father's writings?"
Yes, so I'm very familiar.
But notice who she's going to mention,
Eusebius of Caesarea.
Ignoring the writings before the
Didache,
Justin Martyr, Irenaeus.
Cuz this is a new Karen argument that
they're using. Now, listen to the
argument. Absolutely. Do you have any
kind of dispute on how the church first
>> Yeah, so Eusebius quotes it as go and
baptize only in the name of Jesus. And
Only in the name of Jesus. Did you
notice two things? She added only to the
text. Secondly, Eusebius is 4th century.
What happened to the 1st century, 2nd
century, 3rd century?
Eusebius comes in the 4th century, 300s.
Why is it you ignore all those that came
before?
And why do you add the the word only to
Eusebius' statements?
Okay, listen to how it's being
represented. Okay?
And we also see this echoed within the
book of Acts when the disciples only go
and baptize in the name of Jesus. So,
would you say that baptizing Got you
twice.
Guys, pray the Spirit give you
illumination, open ears to listen
attentively and clearly.
Twice she added the word only, right?
Eusebius said, "Only in the name of
Jesus."
And the book of Acts, "Only in the name
of Jesus." Right? In the name of Christ.
Okay. We're going to see if that's true.
saying the name of Jesus is sufficient
to baptize?
>> I would say, and it's funny cuz now
we're talking about church fathers, but
I would encourage you to read Eusebius
book four. He quotes it the way that I
just quoted it because he says, "Baptize
in the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Spirit."
>> In book four, you said? Because book
four is actually where he quotes it the
way that I said it. Did you hear it?
Book four is where he actually quoted it
the way I said it. Okay, I want you
catch all the errors.
Mhm. Eusebius said only
in the name of Jesus.
Book of Acts agrees only in the name of
Christ, Jesus Christ.
And book four, he cites it the way I
said it, only in the name of Jesus.
You remember these claims, right?
Right? You remember these claims, right?
Yep, I know. But that's nonetheless
Nonetheless, Eusebius of Caesarea will
will grant her that. Okay, Father.
He quotes it both ways. Okay, perfect.
So, would you say that there is a sort
of variant reading in Matthew 28:19? Did
you see what she said?
She then claims that if both readings
exist in Eusebius, that means there were
variant readings in the manuscripts of
Matthew
that Eusebius was quoting from. Do you
understand?
Are you catching these points? Cuz we're
going to have a field day. And by the
way, this is the only clip I've heard
from the debate thus far.
I haven't watched the debate, so we're
going to be watching it live together,
Lord willing, and we'll do several parts
and go through it.
When he posted these clips, God Logic
did, I listened to them.
And I'm going to show you how old this
argument is.
I had to address this argument
over 10 years ago, maybe even 15. That's
how old this argument is. It comes from
so-called Christian Unitarians.
So, she just said, "Well, if Eusebius
quotes it both ways, doesn't that mean
there are variant readings in the mas-
manuscripts of Matthew?" That's the
implication, right? Look at how sharp
Lady Logic is. And then, because if he's
quoting it both ways, then you would
have to say that both readings exist,
right?
>> No, I wouldn't have to say that there's
a variant reading in the text. I would
say that when the church fathers are
reciting it or writing about it, they
can either paraphrase it or they can
quote it directly. So, in this case, he
quotes it directly and he paraphrases
it. Beautiful response, and she's
spot-on.
I produced this post.
It's also on my website.
You remember she said both readings are
in book four of Eusebius. You ready to
learn?
Thank the Lord. Lord bless our numbers
for your glory, not for my praise. Okay,
now watch here.
She said book four, right?
And I'm going to go to an older article
show you the manuscript stream for the
reading.
Well, the only book four
that I found
that Eusebius cites
Matthew 28:19 is here. Let's go down.
Now I give you
a large section
of the writing that I think is relevant
because he's talking about the Gospel of
Christ being spread all over the world.
Syriac Philophonia,
book four, chapter eight, right?
Did you see what she said? She said it's
in the same book four, right?
She said it's in the same book four,
correct?
Okay.
We're just going to put name of
name of.
There it is.
And that he foretold at the outset to
his disciples that he'd make them
fishers of men, that they should
eventually openly, immediately, and
through his power make disciples of all
nations from the Gospel of Matthew.
Let's read. He's now going to quote
Matthew 28:16 to 20.
After his resurrection from the dead,
all of them being together as they had
been commanded went to Galilee as he had
said to them but when they saw him, some
worshipped him. He's now quoting Matthew
28:16 to 20.
But others doubted.
But he drew near to them, spoke with
them and said, "All power both in heaven
and earth
is given to me of my father. Go ye and
make disciples of all nations, baptize
them in the name of the Father and of
the Son of the Holy Ghost. Teach them to
observe all that I've commanded you and
behold, I'm with you always even to the
end of the world." She said, "Both are
found in book four."
No, they're not.
The only other reference is, "Blessed is
he that cometh in the name of the Lord."
That's it.
The name of Christianity.
"I am come in the name of my father."
John 5:43.
The name of John.
Name of the Father and of the Son and
Holy Ghost.
"Blessed is he who cometh in the name of
the Lord."
Really?
Why did she say they're both in this
book, book four?
They're not.
Only this formula is in the book.
And he's telling you he's quoting
Matthew.
Let's see elsewhere, does he quote the
Trinitarian
form
of Matthew's gospel, the Matthean
Trinitarian form of Matthew's gospel.
Can you believe it? I can't find my
phone.
Let's see. All right, you ready?
Now, I'm quoting
Eusebius' By the way, is the screen
large enough? Let me see.
Screen large enough? I'm quoting
Eusebius' response to Marcellus
who wasn't a Trinitarian.
Who wasn't a Trinitarian.
And to refute the
the anti-Trinitarian,
to prove the Trinity,
and to prove the monarchia, the monarchy
of the Father,
to prove the monarchy of the father.
You know what he does? He cites Matthew
28:19
with the Trinitarian formula intact to
prove his case.
All right?
To prove his case.
I think we even need to make it a little
larger. There.
Oh my goodness. Hold on, man.
It's all in this new post. I produced
this post in honor of her.
Let's see it. How many times does he
quote, as I look for my phone,
the Trinitarian
baptismal formula as found in Matthew
28:19. It's right there in front of my
eyes, you dumb little monkey.
Let's see, okay?
It's all there, free of charge, guys.
It's all there.
Free of charge.
I hope you're going to enjoy this
cuz now you're going to learn about
textual criticism, manuscript evidence,
early church writers.
Okay.
So, let's go down.
All right, right here.
This comes from his response to
Marcellus where he tried to prove the
Trinity.
Lengthy citations I give you, so we're
not going to read all of it.
Right?
Why wasn't it quoted here? Oh, I think
it's because he was talking about the
Trinity.
Trinity, right? Okay.
Here you go. Therefore, there's one God,
one mediator of God for all creatures.
The saving mediation beginning not now,
but even before his divine appearance
among men
as the statement has showed
given that these things have been laid
out in brief to the same Galatians from
the only letter addressed to them.
Saving faith provides the mystical
regeneration in the name of the Father
and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit.
That's Eusebius and his work against
Marcellus as he's trying to prove the
monarchy in the Trinity.
Really?
In the name of who?
Let's go back here.
Here it goes again.
I was supposed to highlight this. See,
that's why I didn't see it. Guys, give
me a second as I try to correct
somebody's articles. You're enjoying
this? You're not bored, right?
Why do I make mistakes, dude? I have no
idea. He mentions it three times.
He mentions it three times in his
response to Marcellus.
All right?
But what in the world was this gospel
instead of which there was no other one
if not I suppose that very gospel that
indeed it is recorded that the savior
publicly proclaimed when he was handing
it over to the disciples saying, "Go
make disciples of all nations
baptizing them in the name of the Father
and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit
for he alone through the mystical
regeneration has given to us this grace
of the knowledge of the Holy Trinity."
Hmm.
That's one.
All right. Here it is the second time.
In the name of the Father and of the Son
and Holy Spirit. That's two in his work
against Marcellus.
Here's the footnote, page 85 of his
work.
And here it is three.
For this reason
only this spirit has been received into
the holy and thrice blessed Trinity and
no other way did the savior command his
apostles to hand over the mystery of his
regeneration to those gentiles who
believed in him than by baptizing them
in the name of the Father and of the Son
and of the Holy Spirit.
Why then
were Were given the misleading
impression,
the fake news, that he said baptize only
in Jesus' name?
And why were we told that both formulas
are found in book four? The only book
four where
Eusebius mentions baptism in the name of
the Father, Son, and Holy Spirit,
doesn't have the other formula.